france 2 is placed in the fire
publication experts next year and within
the framework yes to this
express interview stress test experts
european bank with seven ministers this
round and india that in the end a dose of this
mini this winter nor do
you have municipalities  a dialect as egrets
raised the ofs
by bus or in europe readers 10:15 am 2010
endless screw the probable of a fall
explains 1,208 come out with a
bookstore status on our commitment to be
open and smith has his b to c space is
towards  ax at 8:45 this morning his green west
does not found his safes in steinbourg big
flop ps
me my only red line is or blue
is to finally achieve a system
that works to protect the
taxpayers that the banks pay
for the banks that  this
resolution box the preventions is
actually operational european
legislative has taken of this type is out
of trouble
there is on the other hand a spa spirit beats
europe to complain about the ground and scenic but
rémy peak  is beautiful for the i's and
its repression of finances
for the trustee the shadow of the global of the
cops felt it well with
endemic problems san suu kyi
remained here the precision that families
spain with your nothing in the world shasta
but in fact  we will leave protos not here
is the bone to this collectivity
provided that it is framed the state
responsible for the supervision or does not
guarantee importantissime an instrument of
which precisely the twenties it participates
in the source of this system would be the
system  European banking
for us the banking union is a project
an essential instrument to strengthen
the euro area to restore the channels of
financing the economy and
growth under uniform conditions
or without the monetary union I will even
go further
l  banking union and weaken there
is no banking nyon we are
obliged but really obliged
politically to put an end to the
financial fragmentation which constitutes
an element of this fa  iblesse this is
why france defends the adoption in
the current european legislature,
that is to say by march
in practice agreement on the
single supervision on the resolution rules on
the implementation of  a single authority
in the euro zone and on